David Boder: [In English] Geneva, Switzerland, August the 26th, 1946, in a foyer for boys, who are in training in preparation for eh Palestine, mostly. It is a foyer where they live and have other lessons than their professional ones. Rather an old building but surrounded by beautiful gardens. The interviewee, as a matter of fact, I came here when the boys saw me at school and suggested, suggested that I come over. They apparently will be ready subjects. I’m going to stay here this evening. The first interviewee is Wolf Nehrich.
David Boder: [In German] Äh, werden Sie deutsch sprechen oder jiddisch, was wollen Sie reden?
Wolf Nehrich: Ist egal.
David Boder: Ja also, reden sie was sie wollen. Machen Sie’s sich bequem, und brauchen Sie sich nicht zu äh, zu bemühen, ob Sie eine Sprache reden oder die andere. Also Nehrich, sagen Sie mir noch mal den vollen Namen. Wie alt sind Sie, und wo sind Sie geboren?
Wolf Nehrich: Ich heiß Wolf Nehrich. Ich bin geboren in Polen in Debice [wahrscheinlich] am 26. 12. 1928.
David Boder: Ähm, Debice ist in welchem Distrikt?
Wolf Nehrich: Das ist in äh, das ist also, das heißt Debice, das ist in Polen.
David Boder: Near was, welche große Stadt?
Wolf Nehrich: [unverständlich]
David Boder: War es russisch Polen oder deutsch Polen?
Wolf Nehrich: . . . das ist Mittelpolen.
David Boder: Ja, das war Mittelpolen. Also, Nehrich, erzählen Sie mir, äh, was hat Ihnen passiert, wenn die Deutschen sind nach Polen gekommen, wenn der Krieg hat angefangen, und alles was Sie nachher durchgegangen sind. Erzählen Sie wie Sie wollen, sprechen Sie frei, und Sie brauchen sich nicht zu sputen.
Wolf Nehrich: Die Deutschen sind angekommen. Mussten wir flüchten langsam, und trotzdem allem hat man uns gefangen. Wir erfahren die ganze Schule aufgehört. Wir durften nicht mehr lernen wegen politische Gründe.
David Boder: Zu welche Schule sind sie gegangen?
Wolf Nehrich: Zu der Hoch- Hochschule. Eine jüdische Hochschule.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann
Wolf Nehrich: [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Wie alt waren Sie dann?
Wolf Nehrich: Äh, damals war äh ich elf Jahren.
David Boder: Elf Jahre.
Wolf Nehrich: Wie der Krieg anfing.
David Boder: Wie der Krieg angefangen hat? Und wer war in Ihrer Familie?
Wolf Nehrich: So, zwei, noch zwei Brüder und die Eltern.
David Boder: Ihr Vater und Ihre Mutter?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Was hat sich Ihr Vater beschäftigt? Was war seine Beschäftigung?
Wolf Nehrich: Wir haben ein Geschäft gehabt.
David Boder: Auf was?
Wolf Nehrich: Textilwaren.
David Boder: Was?
David Boder: Eine Manufakturgeschäft. Ja. In [unverständlicher Ortsname].
Wolf Nehrich: Nicht in [unverständlicher Ortsname], in Königshütte.
David Boder: Was?
Wolf Nehrich: In Königshütte.
David Boder: Königshütte?
Wolf Nehrich: In Königshütte. Wir haben gewohnt in Königshütte, nachher.
David Boder: Wie heißt das? Königs
Wolf Nehrich: Königshütte.
David Boder: Königshütte. Alright. Das klingt so wie Englisch. Königshütte.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir, ähm: Wie waren, wie alt waren Ihre Brüder und Ihre Schwestern?
Wolf Nehrich: Der jüngere Bruder ist geboren 1930, und der ältere Bruder 1924.
David Boder: Aha. Und äh, Ihre Schwester?
Wolf Nehrich: Hab ich keine gehabt.
David Boder: Aha, also waren bloß zwei Brüder.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: . . . und ihre Eltern.
David Boder: Nun erzählen Sie was hat passiert. Machen Sie’s sich bequem und reden Sie.
Wolf Nehrich: Nach mussten wir übersiedeln in eine andere Stadt, weil in Königshütte wurde judenrein gemacht, mussten wir nach Będzin.
David Boder: Also die Deutschen haben gesagt, dass diese Stadt muss werden von Juden rein.
Wolf Nehrich: Judenrein, ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, mussten wir nach Będzin. Wir sind nach Będzin gekommen musste ich eine, eine, irgendeine Arbeit andre antreten, damit ich nicht nach Deutschland als zwangsweise fahren muss.
David Boder: Aber Ihr Vater hat ein Geschäft gehabt? Was hat er mit dem Geschäft gemacht?
Wolf Nehrich: Das Geschäft hat man uns weggenommen.
David Boder: Was heißt das? Wie hat man das weggenommen?
Wolf Nehrich: Die Deutschen sind gekommen, haben die Schlüssel abgenommen, und haben uns rausgeschmissen, und wir mussten da ohne allem bleiben.
David Boder: Und sind Sie weggefahren mit irgendwelche Sachen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, man konnte nur Kleinigkeiten mitnehmen. Was man so bei sich konnt mitnehmen. Man musste in eine andere Stadt wo nur Juden waren rein. Das war so ein, so ein, wie man das anruft, Ghetto.
David Boder: Ja. Sind Sie selbst weggefahren?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein, mit die Eltern.
David Boder: Ja aber ich meine Sie sind, die Familie ist weggefahren allein. Sie haben ein Billet gekauft und weg ging’s.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Also, nun weiter.
Wolf Nehrich: Und dann bin ich in diese Stadt Będzin gekommen. Da musste man an die Arbeit wieder reintreten, da bin ich in eine Fabrik in eine Nebenschr, Tischlerei rein, äh, reingekommen. Dort hab ich gearbeitet anderthalb Jahre.
David Boder: Sie waren elf Jahre alt, damals, oder zwölf?
Wolf Nehrich: Elf.
David Boder: Elf.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Wie groß waren Sie? Waren Sie ein großer Junge?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein. Natürlich mit elf Jahre ist man noch klein.
David Boder: Nun also, wie hat Sie eine Nebenfabrik angenommen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, dort äh, dort war eine Wehrmachtsfabrik. Dort hat man gearbeitet Kisten für Bomben und für die Wehrmacht Bürotische und Betten und solche Sachen, und dort hab ich auch gearbeitet.
David Boder: Was haben Sie dort getan?
Wolf Nehrich: Äh, bei Maschinen gearbeitet, und so weiter. Mich hat trotz ich noch jung war, man hat mich hingestellt, und ich musste bei sie arbeiten. Die Maschinen waren gefährlich, aber man durfte nichts sagen weil man Jude war.
David Boder: Aha. Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Und äh, gefährdet hab ich bald halbes Jahr bei Meister gearbeitet. Ich war da also halbes Jahr.
David Boder: Als was?
Wolf Nehrich: Also, auch ähm als Tischler.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Und ein, anderthalb Jahr in der Fabrik. War zusammen zwei Jahre. Nachher war schon genug gearbeitet dort in der Fabrik, man brauchte nicht mehr die Kisten für die Bomben und so weiter. Da hat man mich genommen einfach von zu Haus. Wie ich gerade von der Arbeit zurückgekommen bin, und man hat mich geschickt ins Lager.
David Boder: Aha. Erzählen Sie mal, wie hat man Sie genommen vom Haus? Sie sind zurückgekommen von der Arbeit, was hat dann passiert?
Wolf Nehrich: Bin zurückgekommen von der Arbeit. Ist gekommen die Gestapo, mit ein Zettel, dass ich auf der Liste bin, und ich soll mich äh stellen, nicht? Um diese und diese Uhr.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Und ich bin allein...
David Boder: Nun warten Sie mal. Die Gestapo, waren das Polen, waren das...
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] nein Deutsche. Reichsdeutsche.
David Boder: Reichsdeutsche sind gekommen und haben gesagt...
Wolf Nehrich: Ja
David Boder: . . . da müssen sich...
Wolf Nehrich: Ja mit der Liste. Ich muss sie um 3 Uhr Nachmittags stellen.
David Boder: Nun? Den nächsten Tag?
Wolf Nehrich: Am nächsten Tag.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Und dazwischen bin ich in der Nacht weg, und ich hab mich versteckt.
David Boder: Wann?
Wolf Nehrich: Ich hab mich versteckt in der Nacht.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Und dann haben sie mich gesucht, hat man, man hat gesagt ich bin nicht da. Ich bin in der Fabrik. In meine Fabrik war ich auch nicht da. Ich hab in der Fabrik ein Kessel oben versteckt
David Boder: Oh, Sie haben sich in der Fabrik versteckt?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Und dann kam, man hat dann mein Vater genommen als Geisel. Wenn ich mich nicht zustell, dann schickt man den Vater nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Da hab ich Angst gehabt. Da hab ich mich an zugestellt.
David Boder: Und hat man den Vater...
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] da hat man den Vater wieder rausgelassen.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Ich kam nachher in ein Rüstungslager
David Boder: Wer hat Ihnen gesagt, dass man hat Ihren Vater als Geisel genommen?
Wolf Nehrich: Der Bruder ist gekommen in die Fabrik und hat gesagt, dass man den Vater hat genommen.
David Boder: Aha. So sind Sie zurückgekommen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Das war im Jahr 1941.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Und da hab ich mich gestellt. Ich war auf die Polizei. Auf die Gestapo haben sie mich wieder geschickt nach, in ein Rüstungslager, das in eine Nebenstadt. Und von dort hat man uns genommen als Fachmänner, nicht wahr. War als Tischler mit elf, mit zwölf Jahre, hat man uns genommen an die, äh, nach Deutschland.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: In ein Lager. Dort musste schon anfangen zu arbeiten zwangsweise.
David Boder: In welchem Lager war das?
Wolf Nehrich: Sackerau
David Boder: Sackerau
Wolf Nehrich: Das war das erste Lager.
David Boder: Wo ist das?
Wolf Nehrich: Das war in Oberschlesien. Deutsch-Oberschlesien.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Hab ich gearbeitet in ein Wald. Essen war wenig.
David Boder: Was haben Sie dort gearbeitet?
Wolf Nehrich: Man hat Bäume geschnitten.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie getan?
Wolf Nehrich: Auch Bäume geschnitten und rausgetragen auf die Chaussee.
David Boder: War das mit andere Juden?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Nur Juden.
David Boder: Nur Juden. Nun, und wo...
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] mit Bewachung.
David Boder: Was?
Wolf Nehrich: Mit Bewachung.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Deutsche haben mich bewacht.
David Boder: Und wo sind Sie geschlafen?
Wolf Nehrich: In Baracken.
David Boder: Mhm. Nun? Wie lange hat das gedauert, und was ist dann passiert?
Wolf Nehrich: Nach dies hat man mich wieder genommen in, hm ich denke ungefähr wie lange. Hat man uns wieder geschickt als 52 als äh Berufsmänner nach äh Karwin. Das war in Tschechien, Sudentenland.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja und dort waren wir, haben wir gearbeitet statt bei fachmännische Arbeit haben wir bei Beton gearbeitet. Wir ein Kraftwerk aufgebaut. Das Kraftwerk war noch nicht fertig, weil da äh musste man uns wegschicken, da dort viel Partisanen waren. Da hat, haben sie Angst gehabt, dass wir ausreißen langsam, weil es sind viel von diese Lager geflüchtet. Das hat man uns wieder geschickt nach äh Groß Masselwitz. In ein anderes Lager. Dort war ich wieder eine Zeit habe äh gearbeitet.
David Boder: Masselwitz oder Misselwitz?
Wolf Nehrich: Masselwitz, Groß Masselwitz.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: In diesem Lager hat man wieder gearbeitet bei äh, an neuen Autos für die Wehrmacht mal wieder. Neu gemacht und Autobahnlinien. Das heißt, die Chaussee gemacht. Beton, das alles. Neue Autobahnlinien gemacht. Von dort hat man uns wieder, waren schon zu viele Menschen dort, und war wenig zu Essen, hat man uns geschickt nach Klettendorf.
David Boder: Wo ist das?
Wolf Nehrich: Klettendorf ist bei Breslau.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: In ein Lager. Dort haben wir gearbeitet auf dem Feld, haben wir, ja ein Schacht gemacht für Ferngasröhren, aus Gas.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Das waren diese so große Röhren, nicht wahr, haben wir geschichtet äh Erde. Man musste schwer arbeiten dabei. Wir haben sechs Kilometer ein Schacht gemacht. Man musste zwei Meter fünf äh, zwei Meter 20 Tiefe sich...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Graben.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Machen, durch ein Tag. Fünf Meter die Länge.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Wer’s konnte, der konnte, und wer nicht hat Schläge bekommen.
David Boder: Jeder einzige musste fünf Meter lang und zwei Meter 20 tief graben?
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] Lang und zwei Meter 20 ja, durch ein Tag.
David Boder: Zwei Meter 20 tief?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Wenn es, wenn es zu harte Erde war oder steinig, da hat man noch ein Tag zugegeben.
David Boder: Aha. Und äh, was dann wenn er nicht fertig war? Was?
Wolf Nehrich: Hat er, dann hat er Schläge geg-, Schläge ge-, bekommen, und vielleicht manches Mal wenn man, wenn derjenige noch schlimmer gearbeitet hat oder wie, wenn er schwach war, hat er sein Essen nicht bekommen an diesem Tag.
David Boder: Aha. Nun? Äh, haben Sie immer äh genügend gearbeitet?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Ich hab da meistens, ja mal, manche Mal wenn ich hab gute Erde gehabt ging es schneller, und wenn nicht, hab ich genauso lange Schläge, dann geschlagen bekommen wie alle anderen.
David Boder: Wer war das, wer hat Sie geschlagen?
Wolf Nehrich: Der Meister selbst.
David Boder: Wer ist der Meister?
Wolf Nehrich: Der Meister war so ein deutscher Aufseher, nicht? So ein Meister...
David Boder: [unterbricht] war er Häftling, Häftling?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein, nein. Das war ein Reichsdeutscher.
David Boder: Und der Meister selbst hat Sie geschlagen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Und nachher äh waren wir dort dann äh etwa fünf Monate, und dann hat man uns wieder überschickt nach äh Landeshut. Hat man uns genommen, nur äh Jugendliche, so bis äh 16 Jahre, Jugendliche. Man hat uns dort hingeschickt. Man hat gesagt, dass wir dann arbeiten in eine Webereifabrik. Dabei mussten wir auch auf einer Baustelle arbeiten, bei Steine, Steine tragen aus Lehm. Und wir mussten Steinbaracke aufstellen für die Bomb, Bombardierte aus Deutschland.
David Boder: Hm.
Wolf Nehrich: Die, die was sind bombardiert an der französischen Grenze, die haben, sind obdachlos, mussten, sind sie gekommen diese Baracken welche wir aufgestellt haben. Das war ein sehr schlimmes Lager. Es war sehr unrein, und es war nicht gut zu schlafen. Man musste nur auf der Erde schlafen, einer auf dem weiten. Und wir äh, haben wenig zu essen bekommen. Viele sind dort gestorben, vor Hunger und vor Schläge welche und vor Schmutzigkeit. Es waren verschiedene solche Sachen das, die unangenehm sind auszusprechen.
David Boder: Ja, aber wir wollen das wissen.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, zum Beispiel Läuse waren nicht wahr, wie man das nennen soll, und Flöhe und verschiedene die alle die ganze Elemente.
David Boder: Äh, sagen Sie mal wie? Sie sagen Leute sind von Hunger gestorben. Wie stirbt jemand von Hunger?
Wolf Nehrich: Jemand ist, äh, nicht wahr, wenn wenig zu essen bekommt, und wenn er schwer arbeiten muss wird er krank und nachher.
David Boder: Aha, sind selbst krank geworden.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Und was hat....
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] Und wenn man krank wird, wenn man arbeitsunfähig ist, bekommt man verschiedene Einspritze, solche, dass man noch stirbt. Weil sagen sie, wer nicht arbeiten kann, der muss, der ist arbeitsunfähig.
David Boder: Aha. Na hat man Einspritzungen in Ihrem Lager gegeben?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Einspritzungen waren sogar SS-Ärzte, die haben Einspritzungen gemacht von Petroleum. Und sogar wenn jemand Eiter gehabt hat, hat man das Eiter raus, rausgezogen und den Kranken reingespritzt.
David Boder: Wer hat Eiter gehabt?
Wolf Nehrich: Es waren manche die einen Abszess haben gehabt auf dem Fuß oder irgendwie. Hat man mit einer Spritze den Abszess rausgezogen und einem anderen der krank war, der ist schon, der schon im Sterben lag eine Spritze reingemacht mit Eiter, und dann hat er vergiftet bekommen und ist gestorben.
David Boder: Haben Sie das selbst gesehen?
Wolf Nehrich: Selbst mitgelebt, mitgesehen, ja.
David Boder: Wo hat man das getan? Im Revier?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, im Krankenbau.
David Boder: Und wieso waren Sie dort?
Wolf Nehrich: Das, äh, ich bin doch da öfters reingekommen. Manchmal war man brauchte einen Verband, es waren so verschiedene Sachen. Dass man, man wurde [unverständliches Wort] auf der Baustelle, oder irgendetwas raufgefallen, eine Schiene, oder ein Stein auf den Fuß oder irgendwie.
David Boder: Ist man auch zum Revier?
Wolf Nehrich: Natürlich.
David Boder: Und wer hat im Revier gearbeitet?
Wolf Nehrich: Dort waren Ärzte, dort waren Häftlingsärzte, nicht wahr, und es waren äh...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Die SS?
Wolf Nehrich: Es waren jüdische Ärzte und es waren auch SS-Ärzte, Stabärzte.
David Boder: Und wer hat die Einspritzungen gemacht?
Wolf Nehrich: Die SS.
David Boder: Die SS haben die Einspritzungen gemacht. Einfach Eiter genommen von jemands Wunden...
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: . . . und eingespritzt.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Wolf Nehrich: Nachher hat man uns von äh Landeshut schicken. Waren schon, hat man gemacht einen Transport von 30 Kranke, 20 Kranke und 30 äh Gesunde, die noch zur arbeitsfähig sind, die noch zur arbeitsfähig sind sollten sie nach Blechhammer fahren.
David Boder: Nach Blechhammer?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Also ich bin mit mit diesem...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Blechhammer ist near welchem äh Lager?
Wolf Nehrich: Blechhammer ist auch in Oberschlesien.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Also mit, ich bin damals mit in dem Transport nach Auschwitz, da ich, ich war auch krank. Ich war schwach und so. Da hat man mich geschickt nachher nach Auschwitz. Ich kam dorthin, da hat man’s Appell gemacht. Und man hat sich müssen bisschen, die Hälfte ausziehen. Und ein Arzt ist rumgegangen und hat angeschaut wer noch arbeitsfähig ist und wer nicht. Mich hat man noch anerkannt, dass ich noch zwei Wochen arbeitsfähig bin.
David Boder: Was heißt das? Hat man noch zwei Wochen Arbeit...
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] Zwei Wochen arbeiten. Die schon überhaupt nicht arbeiten konnten, die hat man natürlich in die, durch ein großen Tor reingegangen und durch den Schornstein raugegangen, das ist das Krematorium.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Wolf Nehrich: Man hat sie vergast, die starben dann im Krematorium.
David Boder: Haben Sie die Krematorien gesehen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Wie haben sie ausgesehen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ich hab sogar ein Bild vom Krematorium aus Buchenwald.
David Boder: Was?
Wolf Nehrich: Ich hab sogar ein Bild aus Krem, ein aus dem Krematorium aus Buchenwald.
David Boder: Wer hat das Bild genommen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ein amerikanische, die amerikanischen Soldaten nach der Befreiung.
David Boder: Ja, Buchenwald war aber kein Vernichtungslager.
Wolf Nehrich: Es war genauso wie jedes andere Lager.
David Boder: Wieso?
Wolf Nehrich: In Auschwitz war das, war das Krematorium ein wenig größer wie in, wie in äh Buchenwald. Sie haben, in Auschwitz war auch Gaskammer, und in Buchenwald waren keine Gaskammern. Dort hat man aufgehangen. Jedenfalls, ich, in man hat anerkannt, dass ich noch sauber und arbeitsfähig bin, und da hat man mir eine Nummer auftätowiert auf der Hand.
David Boder: Welche Nummer waren Sie?
Wolf Nehrich: 178141
David Boder: hundertachtundsiebzig
Wolf Nehrich: Siebzig, tausend, nicht wahr, hundert
David Boder: einhundert...
Wolf Nehrich: einund...
David Boder: . . . vierzig
Wolf Nehrich: . . . einundvierzig.
David Boder: hunderteinundvierzig.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Und ein Triangel, ohne Triangel?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein.
David Boder: Ah, 141.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Wer hat die Tattoos gemacht?
Wolf Nehrich: Das waren Häftlinge, die extra aus äh, ausgeklaubt waren für diese Sachen.
David Boder: Ja
Wolf Nehrich: Zu tätowieren.
Wolf Nehrich: Und dann hat man...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Und wie hat man tätowiert?
Wolf Nehrich: Es war so eine Feder, nicht wahr, so wie bei einer Injektion, und in der Feder war eine Nadel, so wie eine Injektionsnadel, und man hat äh mit Tusch reingemacht, und das geht nicht mehr raus.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Das bleibt schon eine Zeit. Der Arm [unverständliches Satzende]. Und dann hat man mich, äh, da ich ja arbeitsfähig war, hat man mich zuerst nicht gelassen in Auschwitz. Hab ich nichts, hab ich nicht gearbeitet. Man musste nur solche unnützliche Arbeit machen, Steine tragen von einen Ort auf den zweiten, äh, aufräumen und verschiedenste Sach. Und man musste stehen paar Stunden bei Appell jeden Früh und Morgens, und in der Nacht hat man uns aufgeweckt und nachher mu-, hat man mich hier geschickt äh Blechhammer, auch dorthin. Kam ich nach Blechhammer, hat man, a, bin ich auf eine Baustelle gegangen, wo ein großes Werk war, äh dort hat man Benzin produziert. Dort hat man von Kohle gegraben. Von die Kohle hat man rausgezogen Benzin, und äh, und ein Mittel zu Margarine und ein Mittel zu Saccharin. Das übrige war Koks.
David Boder: Was ist ein Mittel zu Margarine?
Wolf Nehrich: Was hat von die Kohle rausgezogen so ein, so ein Mittel...
David Boder: [unterbricht] ein Stoff woraus Margarine gemacht wird?
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] Ja, Margarine und auch so ein Stoff wo man Saccharin gemacht hat.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Nachher, dort hat man, hab ich gearbeitet bei Schienen, Eisenbahnbau.
Wolf Nehrich: Und das war eine Arbeit äh, die sehr schwer war. Wir mussten Akkord arbeiten, jeden Tag vier, fünf Waggon mit Schiene abladen und Schwellen noch dazu.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Und wir haben immer geladen die Waggons. Es waren, waren viele Unfälle dabei, weil man hat uns gejagt dabei, wir mussten viel leisten. Die Meisters haben immer geschrieen, wir müssten leisten für Reich, für Führer und für Werk. Und wenn...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Für Reich, für Führer...
Wolf Nehrich: Für Führer und für Werk.
David Boder: . . . und für Werk. Und?
Wolf Nehrich: Wir haben keine Lust gehabt dabei, so wie wir Lust gehabt haben damals, weiß ich, irgendetwas zu machen welches man nicht braucht.
David Boder: Nee.
Wolf Nehrich: Jedenfalls, wir mussten das machen. Und äh, das Werk wurde letztens viel, sehr stark bombardiert, und da hat man uns äh, beinah ein halbes Jahr gearbeitet haben auf ein, auf ein Waggon, kam ein Angriff, von amerikanischen Flugzeugen, und man hat das ganze Werk bombardiert.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Und ich, äh, viele immer wir durften nicht uns nicht schützen, Splittergraben. Da hab ich mich geschützt unter ein, ein Stapel von Schwellen. Und so wie ich da...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Von was?
Wolf Nehrich: Von Schwellen.
David Boder: Schwellen?
Wolf Nehrich: Schwellen, ja. Eisenbahnschwellen.
David Boder: [spricht gleichzeitig mit Nehrich] Eisenbahnschwellen.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Und auf einmal äh fiel, fallen paar Bomben. Ich hab mich geschützt ein wenig, vor die Splitter, vor die Bomben konnte man sich ja nicht schützen.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Dann ist, äh, ist gefallen die Bombe, äh eine Bombe von mir ungefähr anderthalb Meter, ungefähr anderthalb bis zwei Meter. Und alles ist in die Luft gefallen mit mir zusammen. Wie ich zurück runtergekommen bin auf die Erde, ich war schon ohnmächtig, wie ich rausgeflogen bin, wollt ich da schreien [unverständliches Wort], aber es ging schon nicht, weil ich war schon ohnmächtig. Bin ich runtergefallen in ein Loch, wo die, eine Bombe schon drin ausgesetzt hatten, so ein Bombentrichter. Und nachher hab ich unten gelegen, und ohne bewusst, das Loch wurde wieder von eine andere Bombe zugeschüttet.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Wurde wieder von eine andere Bombe verschüttet, und ich war unter der Erde ungefähr so zwei Meter. Ich wusste überhaupt nicht, dass ich noch unten rauskomm bekomm irgendwie. Es waren...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Ja, war die Erde ganz über ihnen?
Wolf Nehrich: Über mir. Ganze Steine mit verschiedens. Ich bin unten gelegen, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht war‘s zu tief, war vielleicht nass, da war ein wenig Luft. Eine Stunde bin ich unten gelegen.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Dann haben neben mir äh, waren vielleicht zehn Meter entfernt war ein Splittergraben, dort waren Kriegsgefangene, Engländer und Franzosen. Sie haben sich dort geschützen, weil sie keine, äh, nicht waren unter die SS, bewacht nur unter die Wehrmacht. Sie haben gesehen wie ich...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Die Franzosen und die Engländer waren unter der Wehrmacht?
Wolf Nehrich: Unter der Wehrmacht.
David Boder: [spricht über Nehrich] Die konnten sich schützen.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Und die haben gesehen, wie ich bin in die Luft geflogen, nach dem Angriff wollten sie mich suchen. Weil das waren, wir haben uns immer Kameradschaft zusammen gelebt auf der Baustelle. Haben sie mich gesucht und mich glücklicherweise haben sie mich gefunden nach eine Stunde unter der Erde. Und der rechte Oberarm war gebrochen.
Wolf Nehrich: Nach hat man mich gebracht in, ins Lager. Da musste man mich tragen, und die Leute waren keine Kräfte gehabt damals, weil etwa 75, ungefähr 75 oder 76 Tote an diesem Tag. Und über 200 äh Verwundete. Darunter war ich auch. Da hat man sogar Kraft nicht gehabt mich zu tragen auf die Baustelle, musste man mich ziehen auf der Erde.
David Boder: Warum? Die haben keine Kraft gehabt?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein, die haben keine Kraft gehabt, bissel haben sie mich getragen, bissel haben sie mich auf der Erde geschleppt und verschiedenes. Kein Auto haben wir nicht gehabt, gar nichts. Konnte...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Wie weit war das?
Wolf Nehrich: Dreiviertel Stunde von der Baustelle zu Fuß zu laufen...
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: . . . ins Lager. Nachher sind wir gekommen vor Lager, schon zehn Minuten vor dem Lager noch, da ist ein Auto vorbeigefahren, und hat ein SS-Mann angehalten das Auto und hat uns Auto reingeschmissen. Und man hat mich mit dem Auto in eine, ins Lager reingebracht.
Wolf Nehrich: Dann kam ich ins, in Krankenbau. Hat man, hat man mir probiert den Arm irgendwie zusammenzustellen. Hat man, man hat ihn, er war nur auf einer, äh, auf zwei Orte geplatzt, nicht wahr, durchgebrochen, da hat man zurück in ein Gelenk, so wie’s war, und man hat es, man hat Gips gesucht, und damit man etwas mehr machen soll. Der Arzt war gerade ein polnischer Arzt, ein Jude, der war sehr anständig in diesem Lager, und hat gesagt, weil ich noch jung war, sagt er, wird mich schon irgendwie zu retten mit diesem, und hat mir ein Gipsverband gemacht, der, nach de, äh, der Gipsverband hab ich gehabt drei Wochen. Er sollte sechs Wochen auf der Ha, auf der Arm sein, weil er nur drei Wochen, weil es war schmutzig dort in den Baracken, sind mir Wanzen runtergegangen, unter den, unter den Gips, und dann gebissen, so dass ich konnte nicht mehr aushalten, da hat mir der Arzt nach drei Wochen runtergenommen den Gips. Da hatte ich schon kein Gips mehr gehabt, es war nur ein, eine Rolle Verband, ein Schachtel Verband, da hat er mir ein Stärkeverband gemacht, und noch drei Wochen gehabt. Der Arm ist aber nachher nicht gerade zugewachsen, er ist ein bissel krumm.
David Boder: Und der ist noch jetzt krumm?
Wolf Nehrich: Nicht so sehr. Natürlich ein wenig.
David Boder: Ja. Wo haben Sie den Bruch gehabt?
Wolf Nehrich: Hier oben.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Hier auf diesem Ort. Und nachher, äh, sollte ich, richtig sollte ich nur vier Tage in in Krankenbau bleiben. Weil wenn man so lange im Krankenbau ist, da bekommt man kein Essen, man ist arbeitsunfähig.
David Boder: Krankenbau nennt man, ja?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Das ist der „Revier“. Und nachher schickt man nach Auschwitz wenn man unfähig, arbeitsunfähig und man gibt ins Krematorium. Aber der Arzt hat mich, äh, ich hab ein gutes Auge bei ihm gehabt und so hat er mich jedes Mal wann der Stabarzt ist gekommen aus Auschwitz gekommt, die Kontrolle zu machen.
David Boder: Mhm, nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Wie gekommen, da, da hat er gesagt, hat man mich versteckt in eine Kammer oder irgendwo, damit man mich nicht sieht der Stabarzt, dass ich so lange da bin.
David Boder: Und?
Wolf Nehrich: Und, äh, es, wann der Stabarzt ist gekommen hat man, man hat der Arzt gesagt, dass ich bin schon auf der Baustelle, und da war ich noch dort nach die sechs Wochen, halb hat man mir den Gipsverband runtergenommen, und, äh, hab ich mir, hat hat der Arzt, musste man mir noch, äh, äh die Massage machen. Handmassage. Mit Vaseline und so weiter, dass, damit der Arm wieder gerade ist, weil er steif war von dem Ver-, von der Gips.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Dann bin ich, äh, hab ich, unterdessen gearbeitet in dem Krankenbau beim Arzt, assistiert verschiedenes, die Instrumente ausgekocht, und verschiedenes. Er hat gesehen, dass ich, dass ich, kenn mich auf diese Sachen ein wenig, dass ich bin fähig zu verschiedenem. Und mal bin ich noch bei Operationen mitgestanden, weil der Arzt hat gesehen, dass mir macht das nicht viel aus, wenn ich bei Operationen steh. Es waren verschiedene Amputationen vom Finger und, ähm, äh Abszessen, Phlegmone, verschiedenst geschnitten. Und nachher ist gekommen, war, das war schon 1944, Ende, äh, Ende also schon. Im Dezember, Ende Dezember. Nachher war, es war schon kalt in Dezember. Da sind viele Kranke waren im Krankenbau, da musste ich wieder auf die Bausstelle gehen. Kam ich auf die Bausstelle, hab ich gearbeitet, weil, in, in ein Bau wo es, es bombardiert wurde, da musste man die Maschine raus, die Maschine, die in dem Bau waren, rausziehen, von die, von die, von dem Schutthaufen, wo es bombardiert wurde. Nachher, das war schon am 21. Januar 1945 waren die Russen, die russische Armee war, äh, 6 Kilometer von Lager. Und das war sehr gefährlich, da hat man uns evakuiert, damit die Russen uns uns nicht lebend treffen Lager. Da sind wir damals 4300 Mann evakuiert. Wie weit und wo wir gehen wussten wir nicht. Kein Essen haben wir nicht mitbekommen. Wir wussten nicht wie lange wir gehen werden. Man musste [unverständliches Wort]...
David Boder: Sie haben marschiert?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Als...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Erzählen Sie mir mehr über diesen Marsch, und was hat auf, auf dem Weg passiert.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Wir sind rausgekommen am 21. Januar 1945, und sind wir ange-, sind wir gegangen durch die ganze Zeit, es war Schnee, wir sind durch Berge gegangen und durch Felder. Wir durften die Chaussee nicht gehen, weil es waren die äh, die Wehrmacht hat damals der Rückzug gemacht. Da waren die Chaussee alle vernommen, da mussten wir durch verschiedene Hinterwege gehen...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Und wer hat Sie geführt?
Wolf Nehrich: Essen haben wir nicht bekommen. Es war Bewachung jede paar Meter, 5, 6 Meter war ein SS-Mann, und die Gewehr mit Bajonetts angesteckt. Und wir sind gegangen in die paar, paar Stunden sind andere gefallen vor Frost oder Kälte und so weiter. Zu trinken haben wir nicht gehabt was, und zu Essen hat man uns auch nicht gegeben. Sie haben uns einfach evakuiert. Sie wollten sehen wer es hält, und wer nicht was aushalten wird, der wird aushalten, wer nicht der muss einfach, der hat kein Glück gehabt.
David Boder: Und was hat man getan mit solche, mit die die nicht ausgehalten haben?
Wolf Nehrich: Die hat man äh, rausgenommen von die Reihen und aufs Feld raufgeschmissen, Schnee und zugemacht mit dem Schnee, und das war das Ganze.
David Boder: Ja, aber wenn sie noch nicht tot waren?
Wolf Nehrich: Da hat man sie liegen lassen. Oder hat man sie, manche welche noch mehr ein wenig gekommen schon, die halt noch konnten paar leben, äh, ein paar Stunden leben, hat man sie zugeschossen und nachher raufgeschmissen und welche äh, konnte noch, äh, welche die schon bald absterben, hat man raufgeschmissen auf’n Schnee und nachher hat er, ist er so auf’n Schnee gestorben.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Und äh, dort musste man doch etwas trinken. Da wollen, wollten wir Schnee trinken, da haben die SS-Männer gesagt, dass man darf nicht.
David Boder: Warum?
Wolf Nehrich: Weil wir, äh, wenn krank werden von dem Schnee.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Sie haben, da haben sie uns geschossen mit verschiedenes, und da haben sie auf einmal Angst gehabt, dass wir krank werden. Aber die dachten nicht für uns, die dachten das schlechter damit wir nicht ein wenig trinken sollen.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Nachher sind wir...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Und was haben die SS-Männer gegessen und getrunken? Die haben mitgehabt, oder?
Wolf Nehrich: Die haben vom einen Dorf in zweiten haben sich immer jeden Tag gekauft Verpflegung.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Und wenn nicht sind sie reinge. Ich hab einmal probier, probiert zu flüchten unterwegs. Da bin ich weg in ein Dorf in der Nacht, in ein, äh, in eine Scheune. Und in die, in dieser Scheune bin ich rein in ein Stroh und ich dachte ich bin nun gottalleine. Hunger war ich, das war schon am 8. Tag oder 9. Tag. Ist gekommen der Bauer wann ich war. Hab ich ihm gesagt ein Deutscher, dass ich bin hier, ich bin ähm, man hat uns bombardiert, hab ich gesagt und weil, ich wollte nicht sagen, dass ich bin Jude, dass ich bin mit diese Evakuierte. Da hab ich gesagt man hat uns bombardiert, und jeder eine ist irgendwo ausgerissen, und ich mich in diese Scheune rein, er soll mir was zu Essen bringen. Hat er mir gebracht zu Essen, Brot, nicht wahr, und noch etwas äh Gekochtes. Und auf einmal kommt rein vier SS-Männer in die Scheune. Ist er weg, zurück in sein Zimmer rein, und ich bin geblieben unter diesem Stroh, ich konnte sogar nicht essen, da ich Angst gehabt hab. Und die SS-Männer haben angefangen zu stoßen in Stroh und zu suchen, ob nicht jemand da ist. Sie haben gesucht die Juden dorten eine Scheune in die zweite, ob nicht jemand geblieben ist.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Also, sie haben angefangen zu stechen, ist das Bajonette mir durch die Hand durch so, neben dieser Hand. Hab ich Angst bekommen, dass der nächste Stock bekomme ich in mir rein, dabei hab ich runter geschmissen den Haufen mit dem Stroh und bin rausgekommen.
Wolf Nehrich: SS-Männer haben sich bald so entgegen gestellt mit entgegen mir mit die Gewehre. Und, äh, und sie haben gesagt: Raus! Wie viel seid ihr hier? Hab ich gesagt: Ich bin hier alleine. Sagt er: du schwindelst. Sag ich: Doch ich bin hier, ich glaub ich bin hier alleine. Sie haben weitergesucht, haben sie noch sieben gefunden. Die sieben wussten nicht, dass ich bin da und ich wusste aber nicht, dass die sieben sind da. Ein Glück war das die waren besoffen, und haben sie uns...
David Boder: [unterbricht] die SS waren besoffen.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Sie waren besoffen.
David Boder: [spricht über Nehrich] Nicht Sie waren besoffen.
Wolf Nehrich: Nein. Die SS-Männer waren besoffen. Und da wussten sie nicht was zu machen ist, weil momentan, da haben sie uns gesagt: Was soll man mit euch machen? Und dabei möchten wir sagen sie sollen uns leben lassen, da möchten sie sagen: Gebt uns keine Befehle. Möchten wir sagen: Macht was ihr wollt, dann möchten sie uns einfach schießen. Haben wir nicht geantwortet. Haben Sie uns ge-, gesagt: Los, ran an die Reihe. Und wir haben, wir mussten nachlaufen das ganze Stück, was sie sind gegangen, äh, langsam mussten wir nachlaufen durch den ganzen Schnee und durch die Berge bis wir an der Reihe wieder zurückgekommen sind.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Na hab ich schon...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Waren diese SS-Männer von Ihrem Transport?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Die SS-Männer waren von unsere Juden. Dort sind immer geblieben vier, fünf SS-Männer um zu suchen, ob hier jemand geblieben ist.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Man ist da durchgegangen die Felder, nachher ist man in ein Dorf reingekommen.
David Boder: Die haben euch einfach laufen lassen. Die sagten nachts abzuholen mit dem Transport.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, die sind nachgefahren mit eine Motorzug, und wir mussten zu Fuß laufen.
David Boder: Aha. Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Und, äh, wir sind nachher ge-,ge-, äh gegangen, das war, war schon paar Tage später nach diesem ich geflüchtet bin. Also in einem der Nacht sind wir angekommen nach Groß Rosen.
David Boder: Groß Rosen ist wo?
Wolf Nehrich: Groß Rosen, das ist bei [Greuslitz/unverständlicher Ortsname], das ist nicht weit auch von Breslau, so...
David Boder: Ja
Wolf Nehrich: . . . ungefähr ist man dorthin. Das, äh, bei Schweidnitz, diese Gegend ist man hingefahren danach, das war ein großes Lager auch, ein sehr schlechtes Lager. Dort waren viele Häftlinge, die deutsche Kriegsge-, äh, die Berufsverbrecher und Schwerverbrecher, diese, die schon zehn und zwölf Jahre in Konzentrationslager sitzen für, für ein Mord und so. Das waren alles Deutsche. Und sie haben uns geschlagen als wir da reingekommen sind. Zuerst haben wir bekommen damals ein 80 deka für zwölf Mann. Da hat jeder einen bekommen, einen ein Beiß bekommen, da weil wir reingekommen sind.
David Boder: Das ist, jeder hat abgebissen vom selben Brot?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein, man hat gegeben ein Brot für zwölf Mann.
David Boder: Und wie haben Sie das verteilt?
Wolf Nehrich: Und man hat genommen mit ein Messer jeder ein, bekommen sein Stückchen und das war das Ganze.
David Boder: Wer hat das Messer gehabt?
Wolf Nehrich: Die haben wir bekommen. Wann, jede zwölf Mann hat man uns geborgt ein Messer zu zerschneiden bald wieder zurückzunehmen.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Mann musste das Messer wieder bald zurückgeben. Nachher hat man uns reingejagt. Es war nicht gut zu schlafen. Dort waren schon von verschiedene Transporte evakuiert, sind dorthin gekommen in diese Lager. Da hat man vor allen Dingen in der Nacht hat man uns geheißen gehen. Grade in dieser Treppen runter, und wir wussten nicht wo wir gehen. Es war finster. Man durfte keine Beleuchtung draußen haben wegen die Fliegerangriffe. Statts wir sollten rechts gehen, hat man uns geheißen links gehen, und links war ein ganzer Haufen mit Kot ein ganzer Platz, und wir sind rein in den Kot bis über die Knie. Wir konnten gar nicht raus.
David Boder: Was für ein Kot?
Wolf Nehrich: Kot. Einfach. Gebracht von Felder von verschiedene Seiten, äh von Sand, mit Lehm nassgemacht und so.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Und man konnte bis ü-, bis über die Knie. Und das war da natürlich im Winter. Es war, es war gefroren und dies. Es war doch kalt. Viele haben sich die äh Füße abgefroren, die Zehen und so weiter. Nachher hat man uns ge-, äh, hat man uns geschlagen, dass, damit wir von dem Kot rausgehen in dem, in diese Baracke in diese Halle rein. Man konnte aber nicht schnell laufen, weil von dem Kot kann man doch nicht so, sich nicht so schnell rausbekommen. Doch musste man, we-, wer es konnte, der ist raugegangen, und wer nicht der ist gelie-, geliegen in den Kot bis früh und vielleicht beim Gefunden erfroren.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Ich bin dort auch mit rein in diese Halle. Weil, ich äh, ich hab mir irgendwie eine, ein Rat gefunden damit ich rausbekomme von die Kot hab mich genug lange gequält. Dann bin ich rein in die Halle und hab mich aufgelegt auf die Erde. Kam rein der Lagerälteste, ein Reichsdeutscher, der war auch mit einem, so ein grüner Winkel. Es war roter Winkel auf de, auf der linken Brust, war ein politische...
David Boder: [unterbricht] politische
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, und grüner Winkel Verbrecher.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Da war noch, äh, so schwarze Winkel: Sabotage. Das war so ein grüner Winkel, da hat uns gesagt, alles rau-, rüber auf eine Seite. Die ganze Halle war vollgestopft, dass man konnte sich nicht bewegen, und der hat uns geheißen rübergehen auf eine Seite. Also man konnte nicht, er hat uns geschlagen. Und dann...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Womit hat er euch geschlagen?
Wolf Nehrich: Mit einer Reitpeitsche.
David Boder: Oh, er hatte eine Reitpeitsche?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Nun.
Wolf Nehrich: Dann hat er gesagt, wenn ihr könnt [unverständlicher Satzteil], dann alles raus, und wir mussten noch bis morgens stehen. Also draußen auf dem Appell, man hat gezählt die ganzen Tag. Also drei, vier Tage waren wir dort. Gearbeitet haben wir nicht, wir haben nur die Tote zusammengeklaubt die auf dem Platz gelegen haben. Und im Kot die Erfrorene, man musste sie zeichnen mit einer Nummer auf, aufschreiben auf die Füße ganz groß und ins Krematorium dann.
David Boder: Womit?
Wolf Nehrich: Mit ein Tuschblei.
David Boder: Was?
Wolf Nehrich: Mit ein Tuschbleistift.
David Boder: Mit einem Tuschbleistift.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Hat man denen eine Nummer draufgeschrieben.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Die Nummer die er auf der Arm gehabt hat oder auf der Hose nicht wahr, muss halt beim Ausgezogen wird auf die Knochen aufgeschrieben werden. Alle Menschen waren doch mager, so dass man konnte auf die Knochen schreiben. Dann hat man sie ins Krematorium geführt. Nach vier Tage hat man gesagt wir fahren weiter. Wir wussten nicht wohin man hat uns geführt mit in, in so einer Waggon, waren wir 100 Mann in ein Waggon. Sie, äh, Tierwaggon. Und zwei Posten sind diesen Waggon.
David Boder: Zwei Soldaten?
Wolf Nehrich: Zwei Posten. Ja das waren die zwei SS-Männer. Bewaffnet.
David Boder: Im Waggon auch mit drin?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Aber die haben Viertel Waggon vernommen die zwei, und wir das Dreiviertel.
David Boder: Wieso haben sie Viertel Waggon vernommen? Was haben sie getan?
Wolf Nehrich: Sie haben, die waren doch Deutsche, die haben gesagt, wir wollen doch nicht mit euch zusammen hier sich stoßen. Wir müssen bissel bequemer haben.
David Boder: So was haben sie getan?
Wolf Nehrich: Also haben sie sich ein Viertel Waggon genommen mit ein Brett äh, durchgeteilt nicht wahr. Und bis zu diesem Brett durften wir zu und weiter nicht.
David Boder: Nun.
Wolf Nehrich: Und wir sind so gelegen einer auf dem zweiten. Wir sind nachher vier Tage gefahren. Am 9. Feb äh.
David Boder: Wie ist man rausgegangen wenn man wenn man nötig hatte zur Toilette oder so?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, da haben sie abgestellt, und äh man konnte nicht den ganzen Weg auch fahren. Paar mal Zug ist gestanden, man hat immer bombardiert die Wege verschiedenes. Musste man abstellen sich. Da mussten äh Einzelne raus, wer es brauchte immer zu eins. Und zuerst waren wir daraus bekommen 15 deka pro Tag. 15 deka Brot pro Tag und dann einen schwarzen Kaffee.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Wir sind angekommen am 9. April sind wir gekommen am...
David Boder: 45.
Wolf Nehrich: Am 9. Februar 45 sind wir angekommen nach Weimar. Das ist bei Buchenwald.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: So wie wir äh einige Waggon waren keine Güterwaggon, aber so für Arbeitswaggon, für Ziegel und so, ganz offen. Äh, wie wir angekommen sind um elf um zwölf Uhr ungefähr nach Weimar äh, kam ein Angriff.
David Boder: [spricht über Nehrich] Nachts?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein bei Tag. Mittags. Ist gekommen ein Flie-, Fliegerangriff, zuerst ein Aufklärer ein amerikanische Flugzeug und hat ein Zeichen gemacht, dass überall auf dem Bahnhof steht Militär. Wir waren das, aber der Flugzeug glaubte, dass wir sind Militär. Und nach fünf Minuten später ist bald gekommen eine ganze, ein ganzer Fliegerangriff, und man hat uns bombardiert. Und die Posten hier mussten uns runterbringen, und die Posten wollten sich schützen. Sind die Posten rausgelaufen von die Waggon, haben sie gesehen, dass da Militär ist, und haben sie uns bombardiert. Sind viele damals, ich wurde damals [unverständliches Wort] ins Knie hier, hab ich noch etw- hier ein Zeichen, schon zum zweitem Mal von Bombe. Die Hände hab ich Splitter bekommen, auf die Hände auch, und äh viele Tote, waren manche wurden ganz durch durch, äh, was man konnte durch nicht mehr finden. Nur Stückchen von sich. Und es waren 2 SS-Männer auch äh Tote. Von alle SS-Männer waren nur zwei. Und weil die zwei waren Tote, da haben sie uns nachher geschlagen, weil sie gesagt haben: eure amerikanische Kameraden haben uns bombardiert.
David Boder: Eure amerikanischen Kameraden.
Wolf Nehrich: Kameraden haben uns zwei äh, haben von unsere zwei Kameraden tot gesch-, tot gemacht. Nachher, dann wir mussten wieder zurück zum Appell. Alles anständig, lebend geblieben sind. Von die alle waren noch, von die 4300 Mann, die wir aus Blechhammer rausgekommen sind, sind geblieben bis nach Buchenwald 1200 noch.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Wir sind nach Buchenwald zurückgekommen in der Nacht.
David Boder: [spricht über Nehrich] Alles Männer?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Nein, es sind auch mitgekommen Frauen, aber die Frauen sind nachher von Groß Rosen woanders gefahren.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Soda, also wir sind nachher gekommen 1200 Mann, in der Nacht sind wir erst nach Buchenwald reingekommen. Weil wir mussten noch drei-, dreizehn Kilometer zu Fuß gehen.
Wolf Nehrich: Nach, äh, von Weimar nach Buchenwald. Sind wir in der Nacht reingekommen hat man uns gebracht in so ein Waschraum. Dort hat man uns gebadet. Man hat uns alle Sachen, die wir angehabt haben weggenommen. Man hat uns nur gegeben eine Häftlingshose wieder, eine andere, die neu gewaschen war. Äh, frisch gewaschen, die war sauber. Und eine Jacke und ein Hemd. Und ein Mütze, irgendeine Häftlingsmütze. Ohne Unterhosen, nur so.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Man hat uns reingegeben in eine große so, eine Baracke von Pferdestall, Ställebaracke. Dort sind wir gesessen eine lange Zeit. Bis man hat uns wieder reingebracht ein wenig Suppe. In Buchenwald waren schon, kamen grüne Winkel, wie äh Kapos, und so. Das waren hm, meisten die Leute waren Russen, es waren auch Franzosen, Tschechen verschiedene. Dort war vo-, von ganz Europa alle Nationalitäten, die den Krieg gehabt haben, waren dort Häftlinge.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Also, nachher war ich da für zwei Wochen in Buchenwald. Haben wir auch sehr wenig zu essen bekommen. Man hat uns daher noch Injektionen gemacht gegen Typhus. Wir mussten auf die Baracken, äh, schlafen in den Baracken auf Pritschen. Haben wir anderthalb Meter gehabt Elf Menschen. Einer mit dem Kopf, und der die Füße so, und quer über Verschiedenes wie man nur konnte. Sind viele dort gestorben vor Typhuskrankheiten und Lungenentzündung. Ich bin mit die alle zusammen gelegen, und ich weiß nicht irgendwie ein Wunder, dass ich bin nicht, dass mir kein Fehler dabei nicht äh war. Ich hab kein Fehler dabei gehabt. Wir sind nachher, ra, nachher hat man mich geschickt nach äh, Hannover, als äh, Fachmann, ich war, ich war noch jung aber...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Sie waren Tischler.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, Tischler. Hat man mich geschickt nach Hannover. In eine große...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Nach Hannover?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Hat man uns geschickt ein Transport, äh 200 Mann aus Buchenwald sind gekommen nach Hannover in eine Flugzeugfabrik, und V2 hat man dort ausgearbeitet.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Dort haben wir gearbeitet in dem Werk, nicht wahr, das war unter der Erde. 15 Me, 50 Meter unter der Erde in ein Werk war das...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Und, in Hannover.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Ein Werk unter der Erde?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Und, dort haben wir gemacht, nicht wahr, die Flugzeug äh produzierten. Wir haben sie nicht alleine gemacht, aber wir haben die Teilen dazu gemusst abladen und zusammenstellen und die Aluminium für die V2 geschnitten mit die Scheren, mit die Maschinenscheren, und das alles mussten wir machen. Schwereres Arbeit bei diesen Sachen.
David Boder: Alles bloß Juden?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein, es waren dort Italiener auch und es waren Juden. Es waren ge-, andere Nationalitäten auch von verschiedene Länder...
David Boder: [unterbricht mit einer unverständlichen Frage]
Wolf Nehrich: Nein. Die waren nicht. Es waren Franzosen, Tschechen, Jugoslawe, Italiener und Pole und Österreicher auch und Deutsche. Von verschiedene die Nationalitäten.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Nachher, äh, war dort eine Halle, die kei- Juden Eintritt verboten gehabt haben dort. Das war nur für äh für Reichsdeutsche. Dort hat man die Pläne gemacht, und dort waren Maschine, die, die die V2 schnell zusammengestellt haben und das Dynamit reingeschrau-, reinge-, reingetan in die V2.
David Boder: Waren die auch Häftlinge da?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein. Dort durften nur die Reichsdeutsche, die höhere Sachen waren, höhere Fachmänner...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Rein.
Wolf Nehrich: . . . reinkommen. Einmal musste ein, äh, ein Meister, das war also ein Reichsdeutsche, der musste eine große Platte mit Aluminium hereinbringen in diesem, in diesen Raum wo die Juden nicht durften reingehen und hat mich gesagt ich soll mit reinnehmen. Hab ich ihm gezeigt: da steht doch da ein Schild äh ich hab mit der Hand gezeigt, dass dort steht ein Schild aufgeschraubt: Nur für Reichsdeutsche. Juden Eintritt verboten.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Da sagt äh da macht er mit der Hand schaut er mich, komm, niemand sieht. Der Posten war gerade umgedreht.
David Boder: [In English] Spool Number 76. Wolf Nehrich continues the interview.
David Boder: [In German] Also, wie, wo waren Sie?
Wolf Nehrich: Also, ich hab nachher reingenommen die Platte mit diesen Aluminium
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Äh, in dies, äh in diesen Raum, wo die Juden durften nicht reingehen und geh vorbei durch eine Maschine wo, äh, eine große Maschine, nicht wahr, und wollte irgendetwas machen, damit, damit ein, ein wenig Sabo Sabotage gemacht wird, und dass niemand mich schaut dabei. Hab die eine, nur eine Mutterschraube rausgedreht und bin da wieder weggegangen. Niemand hat mich dabei gesehen. Gemacht hab ich’s deswegen grad in diesem Raum, weil dort waren Juden verboten reinzutreten, und dann wär’s klar, wenn was passiert dann sind nur die Reichsdeutschen schuldig und nicht wir. Niemand hat Schaden, nur diese. Und äh, das war streng, das wird streng bewacht, und wenn man mich nicht sieht, dann gelingt es mir. Und, ich hab nur eine Sch Mutterschraube runtergedreht und sie weg, mit dem Fuß weggeschoben. Nachher bin ich rausgegangen. Zwei Tage ist die Maschine gegangen, und am zweiten Tag schon so gegen Feierabend hört man ein großen Krach, die Maschine fällt zusammen.
David Boder: Nu.
Wolf Nehrich: Man wusste nicht, wer das gemacht hat. Man wollte nachforschen, aber die Meister selbst haben nicht wollen nachforschen, weil sie dachten, dass das sei ihre Schuld. Aber das durfte noch niemand sagen. Dieser Meister, der mich reingenommen hat, wo, wollte, wusste, ist vielleicht auf diesen gekommen, dass ich das gemacht hab. Aber da er Angst gehabt hat zu sagen, weil er mich doch reingerufen hat. Er durfte mich nicht. Wenn er etwas sagt, dann nimmt man mich, und man nimmt ihn auch. Ihn selbst. Deswegen hat er nichts gesagt. Und es war für sie schon damals kein Unterschied die Deutsch, weil sie wussten, dass sie schon bald verspielt haben.
David Boder: Die haben das gewusst?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Nun wie haben, hat sich das herausgezeigt? Dass sie gewusst haben?
Wolf Nehrich: Das was?
David Boder: Äh, wie haben...
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] Dass Sie verspielt haben?
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Sie haben gesehen, dass die amerikanische Front schon langsam mal näher kommt. Sie waren schon nicht weit von Hannover und immer vorne. Nach zwei Tage später, wie ich das gemacht hab, hat man uns schon wieder zurück nach Buchenwald gebracht, weil dort schon die amerik-, die amerikanische Front war.
David Boder: Wer hat Sie zurückgebracht nach Buchenwald?
Wolf Nehrich: Die Deutschen. Die SS hat uns, genauso wie man uns von Buchenwald nach Hannover gebracht hat, hat man uns wieder von Hannover zurück nach Buchenwald...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Im Zug oder gegangen?
Wolf Nehrich: Auf dem Wagen. Nur Zug.
David Boder: Man hat’s nach, nach Buchenwald.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Und, was war dort?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Kamen wir zurück nach Buchenwald. Dort hat man mich schon wieder evakuiert mit dem ganzen Transport. Da hat’s geheißen auf Evakuation nach Theresienstadt, aber die haben reingenommen in ein Zelt vom Lager in ein äh Wald und man hat sie alle ausgeschossen,
David Boder: Wieso wissen Sie das?
Wolf Nehrich: Weil nach der Befreiung sind wir, haben wir die, das doch gesehen. Wir haben nachher, die armen Toten waren in Säcken, und man hat sie nachher gebracht in, ins Lager, und man hat sie begraben.
David Boder: Hat man sie in Buchenwald begraben?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Also neben Lager.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: War ein großer Friedhof nach der Befreiung gemacht.
David Boder: War das der Platz, wo man hat gemacht die Deutschen zu sagen wie [unverständliches Satzende].
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, die Deutschen mussten nachher kommen mit diesem, die Tote hintereinander auf den Friedhof. Zu dem komm ich noch nachher.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Also, ich hab mich damals gedreht in verschiedenste, ich hab mich zwischen die Tote gelegt, wo es waren schon paar.
David Boder: Warum?
Wolf Nehrich: Man soll meinen, dass ich bin tot. Dann evakuiert man mich doch nicht.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Die Tote bleiben [unverständliches Satzende]. Wenn ich auf Evakuation geh, dann weiß ich, dass ich schon kaputt bin. Und damit die Leute gehen äh alleine, dass war damit man sie nicht äh ziehen muss, oder äh suchen, hat man gesagt, dass beim Ausgang gibt man zwei Brote.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Das ist wenn sie eher dann gehen. Manche waren so, dass, die haben sich voll Tasch, die wollten haben die zwei Brote sind schnell hin und die zwei Brote haben sie nicht gesehen nur sie haben gesehen den Tod nachher vor sich. Und ich hab gesagt, wenn sterben, dann kann ich sterben hungrig, muss ich nicht essen und bin nicht gegangen. Hab mich versteckt in verschiedene Kanäle und zwischen die Tote, so dass ich bin immer geblieben. Dann bin ich wieder. Ist gekommen ein äh Fliegerangriff mit sieben Flugzeugen, und, und die SS hat gesagt, wir müssen warten bis ein Befehl kommt. Und das waren damals 2000 SS-Männer haben sich hingelegt auf ein großen Platz zwischen die Kasernen rundrum in so [unverständliches Wort]. Und die Flugzeuge haben sich runtergelassen mit Maschinengewehr. Sieben Flugzeugen haben damals die, alle SS-Männer ausgeschossen, die 2000 die dort gelegen haben.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Mit Maschinengewehr. Haben nicht bombardiert.
David Boder: Das waren die amerikanische...
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] Amerikanische Flugzeuge.
David Boder: Sie haben nicht bombardiert.
Wolf Nehrich: Nein, nicht.
David Boder: Haben Sie erkannt, dass SS, SS-Männer sind?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja man sieht doch die Kasernen mit die, äh Hakenkreuz und man sieht da auch die Uniform von die SS.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Sieht man doch, dass das Militär ist. Und noch dazu, wenn sie sich schützen.
Wolf Nehrich: Liegen doch auf die Erde ausgezogen, weil sie dachten, das vielleicht schütze sie irgendwie. Und es war noch im Hellen.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Nachher hat man gesehen, dass was, dass die SS-Männer schon nicht da, sie kaputt sind. Hat man bald gemacht ein Zwischenschutz, [unverständlicher Satzteil] Lager, für für das Lager.
Wolf Nehrich: Für die Evakuation, für die Bewachung.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Also hat gebracht andere statt die 2000 nicht wahr, und man hat uns vor allem, sind wir damals ausgerissen, alle Lager, die Flugzeuge nach dem, nach der Schlacht sind sie über Lager ein bissel rumgeflogen, dann sind sie wieder weg.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, wer hat diese 2000 SS-Männer aufgehoben, weggeräumt?
Wolf Nehrich: Sind bald gekommen Auto, verschiedene Leute, großes Auto. Nicht wahr, die Deutschen und man hat sie reingenommen auf die Auto und sie weggeführt. Wohin weiß man nicht. Wir haben nur gesehen die Auto, die Lastauto vom äh Roten Kreuz.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Genauso wie die alle, andere Verwundete und Kranke von der Front.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Also, wir waren noch damals, das äh, das war ungefähr, vielleicht 7. oder 8.
David Boder: 8. was?
Wolf Nehrich: Am 8. äh...
David Boder: April?
Wolf Nehrich: April ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Also, wir haben noch äh ein paar Tage dort zwischen mein Block wo Jugendliche waren. Nicht wahr, und wir sollten doch evakuieren nächsten Tag, das war schon am 10.. Hat man uns gesagt wir müssen nächsten Tag evakuieren. Damals war noch ein ganzes St, es waren vor dem Tag, eine Woche 70 000, 71 000 Häftlinge.
Wolf Nehrich: Oder 72, je nach, es wurden 51 000 ausgeschossen und 21 000 wurden befreit.
David Boder: Wie? Ein Viertel, wie viel wurden...
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] 72 000 waren.
David Boder: Ja. Wie viele wurden ausgeschossen?
Wolf Nehrich: 51
David Boder: Wer hat sie geschossen? Und wie?
Wolf Nehrich: SS hat sie genommen in eine Wald und in die Menge reingeschossen, und äh, einfach ausgeschossen.
David Boder: Und dann wo sind die Körper geblieben?
Wolf Nehrich: Im Wald sind sie geblieben.
David Boder: Die toten Körper sind...
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] Ja.
David Boder: . . . im Wald geblieben?
Wolf Nehrich: Im Wald. Im Wald, auf dem Feld. Es ist nicht so, wenn man schießt auf den ein auf den zweiten. Da nimmt es nicht so viel Platz.
David Boder: Na, haben Sie das gesehen?
Wolf Nehrich: Wir haben nachher die Tote doch gesehen, und sind doch einige ausgerissen von die Toten.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Von diese, die noch mal ausge-, äh, geschossen äh, wie man sie schießen wollte sind einige ausgerissen.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Nach der Befreiung haben wir sie getroffen in Städte, und haben uns das alles erzählt.
David Boder: Aha. Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Und, äh, also, die sollten nächsten Tag äh evakuieren, und dann kamen um vielleicht 11 oder, um elf oder um zwölf, denn genau beim Alarm, das heißt Handalarm. Das war, das hat geheißen, das war fünf Minuten eine Sirene, das heißt, dass die Front da nähert sich. Die amerikanische Panzer sind langsam, kommen langsam immer näher. Und da dachten wir, dass wir jetzt ist schon alles in Ordnung, wir werden vielleicht leben. Und manche haben geglaubt, dass nicht. Man kann doch im letzten Moment das Lager sprengen. Es waren Kabel zugezogen von auswärts äh, von einer anderen von äh Außenlager ins Lager rein. Das war im Fundament. Konnte man nur auf einen Knopf drücken und das Lager wird gesprengt. Wir wussten nicht, ob es gelingt uns da raus, ob nicht. Man konnte den Kabel nicht durchschneiden, weil der Kabel war außerhalb vom Lager.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Man konnte nicht zukommen zu. Und der Stacheldraht war mit äh elektrisch geladen. Wir sind äh, also, nach dem haben wir gesehen, dass die Panzer kommen an, [unverständliches Wort], man hat schon von Weitem get-, die Panzer fahren. Da haben wir durch die Fenster rausgeschaut. Oben waren kleine Öffnungen in den Fenstern, da hat man rausgeschaut. Und wir haben gesehen, dass, wir haben gesehen den Stern auf, ein weißer Stern auf ein Panzer nicht wahr. Wir haben’s noch selbst nicht geglaubt, dass das sind die Amerikaner, aber doch hat man gesehen den weißen Stern.
David Boder: Und wo waren die SS?
Wolf Nehrich: Die SS hat damals schon rausgezogen sich vom Lager. Einige, sind einige geblieben. Und die Amerikaner waren auf eine Chaussee. Da kommen die, alle, alle SS schon nicht weg. Sind einige geblieben, haben sich überz-, übergezogen andere Sachen, Zivil und wollten rüber. Haben sie gesehen, dass die Panzer fahren, da sind sie, haben sie Graben gemacht und haben sich in dem Graben versteckt.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Die konnten über die Chaussee nicht durch. Dann ist ein Panzer bald rum, über das Lager. Die wussten, dass das dort äh, dass das ein Konzentrationslager war. Weil vor ein Tag früher ist ein Flugzeug durchgekommen. Das war am 10. Der Tag, es war schöne Sonne. Und hat ein paar Zettel runtergelassen, dass morgen, sie geben sich die Mühe, damit sie morgen kommen. Und hat ein leeres Fass von dem Flugzeug von Benzin rausgeschmissen, mit ein Brot, ein weißes amerikanisches Brot.
Wolf Nehrich: Die Freude war so groß. Es ist klar es jedem, einen jedem dort gefallen. Es haben sich viele auf den Brot geschmissen, so dass jeder nur ein kleines Stückchen. [Unverständliches Wort] hat’s ganz zerrissen.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Die Zettel sind aufgefallen nur bei uns im Lager, und einige Zettel sind gefallen, nur ein paar, zwei, vielleicht drei, sind rübergefallen übern Zaun. Hat dann, SS-Männer haben die Zettel gefunden, dass äh...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Und wie waren die Zettel gedruckt?
Wolf Nehrich: Die Zettel waren gedruckt, dass sie morgen kommen. Es war so Blockschrift, oder gedruckt?
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Einfach so.
David Boder: Mimeographiert.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Und äh, nachher ist eine Panzer rumgekommen über das Lager, es war um das Lager ganz. Und ist bald in Tor reingefahren.
Wolf Nehrich: Ein große Riesenpanzer. Und ist das ganze Lager inwändig rumgefahren, hat man weiße Fahnen rausgehangen und verschiedene Sachen auf die Dächer haben wir sie raufgenommen, haben gewunken zu die Flugzeuge. Sind bald Flugzeuge angekommen, zu welche wir gewunken haben.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Und äh, wir haben schon gesehen es war das jetzt sind wir befreit. Sie haben behalten Lager Munition und Gewehre und Maschinengewehre verschiedens.
David Boder: Wer hat die behalten?
Wolf Nehrich: Das haben die politische Häftlinge gehabt vorbereitet, falls kommt der Moment.
David Boder: Wann?
Wolf Nehrich: Und die haben gearbeitet außerhalb dem Lager in ein [unverständliches Wort] das, dort hat man Munitionfabrik, äh hat man Munition produ-, äh produziert. Da haben sie das manches Mal, konnten reinschmuggeln ins Lager solche Kleinigkeiten. Und von da haben sie’s zusammengestellt, haben sie nachher gehabt Gewehre und Munition. Und äh, die äh, Pulver, nicht wahr, die eine Kanone alles zu schießen. Wir äh, wir haben gesehen, nicht wahr, dass der Panzer schon da ist, und mehrere Panzer kommen an und Lastauto verschiedens. Damals sind gekommen die ganz, die Panzerfahrer, die Amerikaner, die drittisch, die dritte Armee war das.
David Boder: Und was war die [unverständliches Wort] Armee?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein die Panzer, äh.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Das war ganz Riesenmenge, die haben sie angeschaut, da hat man sich gewundert, dass die so groß sind, und so weiter. Und, äh, zwischen die meisten waren auch Neger.
David Boder: Neger waren da?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Zwischen die ersten Fahrer. Und die sind reingekommen ins Lager dort und haben uns Schokolade gegeben und alles zu essen, und wir haben gehabt alles bald was wir wollten. Aber die politischen, die Häftlinge die älteren, die mehr Kraft gehabt haben, haben genommen Zangen die isoliert waren mit Gummi und haben das Stacheldraht aufgetreten, aufgerissen und die Kabel bald durchgeschnitten.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Und, damit es noch nicht etwas passieren kann. Man hat rausgelassen mit die Gewehre, man hat die SS-Männer, die noch hinter dem Lager waren, zwischen der Chaussee und Lager, mitgebracht ins Lager reingenommen. Man hat sie nachher aufgehangen und geschossen, rein in einen Bunker, man hat sie geschlagen äh. Sie haben ein wenig Rache genommen. Man kann nicht sagen, die ganze Rache, weil die haben uns mehr gemacht, dass sie uns die Eltern weggenommen haben und das alles. Es war nur eine kleine Rache, muss man sagen.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Nachher, äh, zufällig...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Und darum hat man die SS aufgehangen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja natürlich.
David Boder: Wer hat das getan?
Wolf Nehrich: Die Häftlinge.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Also wir.
David Boder: Haben die politischen Häftlinge das zugelassen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, die, wir waren doch alles waren nur politische Häftlinge, wir mussten dass es.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Und, äh. Grade am selben Tag wann wir wurden befreit damals im 11. April ist gek-, kommt rein einer, in unseren Block, das war in dem Block 66, ein Jugendblock. Und, wir wussten nicht, gewiss ein Amerikaner...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Ein Jugendblock?
Wolf Nehrich: Ein Jugendblock, ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Es waren gekommen ein Amerikaner mit ein Helm, von die Panzer auf, also äh ja. Er sagte uns, er ist ein Jude, er ist Rabbiner, er hieß Rabbiner Schächter aus New York aus Brooklyn.
David Boder: Rabbiner Schächter aus Brooklyn?
Wolf Nehrich: Rabbiner Schächter aus Brooklyn, ja. Und wir haben uns damals, die Freude, die Freude war sehr groß, er hat uns ein paar Worte gesprochen, so dass die Herze haben sich uns ein klein bissel erleichtert, das wir von einem jüdischen Amerikaner ein, der uns ausgelöst hat, nicht wahr, hier von diesem mit einer Armee. Und hat uns gesagt, nicht wahr, dass wir äh, sie wer, äh er wird sich kümmern um uns und so weiter. Also wir wurden ja, wurden nachher rübergenommen eine andere äh schon nicht in Lager. Alle Jugendlichen wurden...
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: . . . übersiedelt in ein Ka-, SS Kaserne, wo früher die SS war haben wir nachher ge, gewohnt. Weil äh die Baracken war verschmutzt, waren viele verschiedene.
David Boder: Haben Sie übergesiedelt in die SS Kasernen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. In die SS Kasernen.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Und damit, dass wir besser leben so ein wenig schon. Ein bisschen normaler, weil wir waren ganz verwildert damals, und wir wussten ganz viel von der Freude von der Befreiung zu machen. Man ist gesprungen, man ist ganz verrückt geworden damals. Und äh, zuerst haben wir damals sehr viel bekommen von die Amerikaner, nicht wahr, wir haben die Deutsche von der Stadt, von de Deutschen mussten liefern verschiedenes Fleisch und äh Butter verschiedene Sachen. Und alle die haben alle...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Gab’s all das?
Wolf Nehrich: Natürlich, es gab Wirtschaft alles, nicht wahr, ganze Felder, und Kühe alles, da mussten sie liefern alles nach Buchenwald. Und ein Teilkontingent konnten sie sich nur leisten. Wir sind nachher in die Kasernen gekommen. Hat...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Ein Teil von was?
Wolf Nehrich: Von dem Kontingent, nicht wahr was sie abgeben mussten fürchten sie sich [unverständliches Wort] nachher in die Kasernen gekommen, hat uns der äh Rabbiner Schächter nicht mehr abgelassen, der hat uns immerzu uns alles besorgt, ist jeden Tag gekommen mit dem Taxi und hat zu uns gesprochen Verschiedenes und hat Verschiedenes mitgebracht was man nur so brauchte von Kleidung und all den verschiedenen Sachen. Und hat nach sehr viel gesorgt. Nachher hat man genommen [unverständliches Wort]. Drei Monate waren wir noch Buchenwald nach der Befreiung.
David Boder: [spricht über Nehrich] Drei Monate noch in Buchenwald?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Aber Sie haben schon frei gelebt?
Wolf Nehrich: [spricht Unverständliches über Boder]
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, wir sind ge-, wir waren ganz frei, das äh man konnte schon nicht frei sagen, noch zu frei war man.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Man konnte Rache nehmen an die Deutschen. Man konnte SS Männer fangen, ist man ein bisschen rumgefahren mit den amerikanischen Jeeps in die Dörfer, und wir haben, wo wir haben nur eine verdächtigt gehabt, haben wir ihn bald mitgenommen, und wir haben in Bunker reingesetzt. Wir haben einige aufgehangen, wir haben den Rapportführer von Buchenwald gefangen, haben wir aufgehangen.
David Boder: Wenn haben Sie gefangen?
Wolf Nehrich: Den Rapportführer aus Buchenwald.
David Boder: Wer war das?
Wolf Nehrich: Das war der im jeden Tag den Appell gemacht hat. [Unverständlicher Satzteil]
David Boder: [spricht über Nehrich] War das ein Häftling?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein, ein SS-Mann.
David Boder: Ja?
Wolf Nehrich: Das ist...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Wo haben Sie ihn gefangen?
Wolf Nehrich: Wir haben ihn in einem Lager, in Weimar.
David Boder: Man hat ihn in Buchenwald aufgehangen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Haben die Amerikaner das zugelassen?
Wolf Nehrich: Natürlich.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Und, die Amerikaner selbst konnten diese Sachen nicht machen, weil bei der Erschießung sie haben, sie waren zu weich, haben sie immer gesagt.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: [Unverständlicher Satzanfang] das zu machen. Haben sie immer gesagt, macht ihr, wir wollen nicht sehen. Aber es war unter diese vielen Juden, die mehr Hass gehabt haben. So dass...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Unter wem?
Wolf Nehrich: Unter den Amerikanische waren doch manche Juden. Da haben sie mehr Hass gehabt. Da haben sie, weil sie wussten dass, das, haben die Deutsche am meisten nur die Juden umgebracht. Da haben sie ja Rache genommen. Die meisten.
David Boder: Mhm.
Wolf Nehrich: Also, wir waren auch, damals sind wir auch in die Dörfer gegangen. Wir haben vieles angetan und verschiedenes an die Deutschen. Und dann kam eine Zeit, die wir da, mussten wir sind wir, haben wir mit der Rabbiner Schächter zusammen geschafft ein Transport. Ein Judentransport, der nach die Schweiz fahren soll. Und wir sind alle abgefahren, 53 Jugendliche sind wir gekommen nach die Schweiz. Schweiz auf Erholung. Ich bin mit ihnen mitgekommen. Und der Rabbiner Schächter war der Transport-, äh -leiter von diesem Zug. Wir waren gefahren etwa vier Tage. Aufm Weg durch Deutschland hat der Rabbiner Schächter mit uns freitags abends äh äh ge-...
David Boder: gebetet?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, gebetet. Nicht wahr. Es war sehr schön die Weg und so weiter. Es war Frühling. Man musste noch ein bissel auch [unverständliches Wort] nach die ganze, nach dem ganzen Zores, wie man sagt. Und wir sind in die Schweiz angekommen.
David Boder: Man hat Sie in die Schweiz geführt?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Mit dem, mit dem Zug.
David Boder: Ja. Mit welchem Zweck?
Wolf Nehrich: Erholung.
David Boder: Auf Erholung.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Es hat nur auf drei Monate. Weil von drei Monate...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Ja. Die Schweiz hat Sie reingelassen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, auf drei Monate. Wir sind gekommen einige, Schweiz hat uns eingeladen auf Erholung.
David Boder: Wer dann?
Wolf Nehrich: Schweizerische Rote Kreuz.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Die nächsten drei Monate. Also, drei Monate wo sollten wir dann nachher gehen?
David Boder: Wie viele sind reingekommen?
Wolf Nehrich: 350.
David Boder: Und Schächter ist mitgekommen?
Wolf Nehrich: Schächter ist mitgekommen, nachher musste er aber bald weg.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Wir haben uns mit ihm verabschiedet. Der Abschied, Verabschied war sehr schön natürlich. Es war uns sehr traurig, dass er uns äh, verlässt. Wir wollten gerne noch mit ihm sein, und so, aber er durfte nicht da bleiben, natürlich. Er war Verantwortung, hat er doch gehabt, weil er doch militärisch und so.
Wolf Nehrich: Musste er doch gehen zu seiner Armee. Also ist, äh er ist weggefahren und hat wieder andere Transporte gemacht, die wieder nach Palästina gefahren sind, und so weiter. So, einige auch nach Frankreich gefahren dort geblieben, weil wir sind durch Frankreich gefahren. Nachher waren wir, sollten wir noch drei Monate da sein, aber wir hatten noch nicht Karten zurück, in der Heimat wollte niemand äh niemand zurück.
David Boder: Warum?
Wolf Nehrich: Das, natürlich der Antisemitismus war und Verschiedenes, in Polen zum Beispiel was tut sich, hat sich getan und auch noch heute.
David Boder: Nun? Ja?
Wolf Nehrich: Wollte niemand zurück. Also, dann sind wir noch geblieben in der Schweiz, man hat verschieden, man hat verschiedene Berufe gelernt.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Zum Beispiel die ORT hat uns äh, hat ge-, hat gemacht, wir haben erfahren, dass sie es da ein ORT-Schule, die sehr gut ist, Berufsschule. Man kann verschiedene Kurse lernen.
David Boder: Und die Schweizer haben Ihnen erlaubt zu bleiben?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Das wurde schon all erledigt durch irgendwelche Flüchtlingshilfe und so weiter, damit dass man hier bleibt, bis wir eine Möglichkeit haben auszureisen. Viele von uns, äh, die meisten, größter Teil wollen nach Palästina fahren, andere wollen wieder nach Amerika gehen, hatten Verwandte da. Nur nicht zurück in die Heimat.
David Boder: Aha. Sagen Sie, haben Sie was von Ihren Eltern gehört?
Wolf Nehrich: Von meine Eltern hab ich nur gehört im 43. Jahr hab ich einmal gehabt ein Gruß.
David Boder: Nun?
Wolf Nehrich: Sonst gar nichts.
David Boder: Wo waren sie da, im 43. Jahr?
Wolf Nehrich: Da waren sie noch in Będzin, wo ich wurde weggenommen. Nachher wurden sie ausgesiedelt.
David Boder: Wie wissen Sie das?
Wolf Nehrich: Ich hab äh, jetzt gefunden ein Bruder nach der Befreiung.
David Boder: Wo?
Wolf Nehrich: Hat mich ein Bruder zufällig gefunden. Der äh, war die ganze Zeit in ein Dorf versteckt als [unverständliches Satzende]
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Ist er noch. Und äh, als äh Nichtjude und hat dort gearbeitet, die wussten nicht, nicht wahr, dass er Jude ist und Verschiedenes, und dann hat er mich auf einer Liste gefunden und hat mir ein Telegramm geschickt.
David Boder: Von wo?
Wolf Nehrich: Eine Liste. Ich war auf einer Befreiungsliste aus Buchenwald. Da hat erfahren, dass ich...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Aber wo war er? In Polen?
Wolf Nehrich: In Polen, ja.
David Boder: Und er hat Sie auf der Liste gefunden?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Und dann hat er erfahren, dass ich in der Schweiz bin.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Und hat mir ein Telegramm geschickt, nicht wahr. Natürlich war die Freude sehr groß. Weil von Verfolgter sollte jedem zwei geblieben.
David Boder: Hat er Ihnen nachher...
Wolf Nehrich: [unterbricht] Und er hat mir nachher geschrieben, wieso er ist entkommen und wieso die Eltern wurden ausgesiedelt, und wann, und so weiter. Hab noch den älteren Bruder gehabt, schreibt er, hat er mir geschrieben, dass der ältere Bruder war mit einer Gruppe jüdische Jugend versteckt in ein, auch in so ein Dorf, ein kleines Städtchen und ein Pole hat sie ausgegeben, und man hat sie alle ausgeschossen.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Mein Bruder.
David Boder: Und wo ist Ihr Bruder jetzt?
Wolf Nehrich: Der jüngere Bruder ist jetzt in Deutschland. Er war in so einer Kibbutz, nach Palästina fahren will. War in Polen in Kibbutz, es ist, war in Deutschland in der amerikanischen Zone, Landsberg, und jetzt ist er wieder in, in der französischen Zone. Hier an der Schweizer Grenze. Ich gebe mir jetzt die Mühe, damit ich mit ihm mich...
David Boder: Ihn sehen.
Wolf Nehrich: . . . wenn ich ihn sehen kann, ja. Weil schon fünf Jahre sind vorbei, [unverständliches Satzende].
David Boder: [spricht über Nehrich] Nun kann er nicht nach der Schweiz kommen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ich gebe mir die Mühe, aber es geht vorläufig nicht. Die Schweiz, Schweiz will nicht reinlassen, jetzt.
David Boder: Ja. Sagen Sie mir diese Sachen, Sie haben sich welche Sachen geschrieben. Ist da etwas, das Sie mir noch sagen wollen? Jetzt sehen Sie nach.
Wolf Nehrich: Da ist alles äh. Das hab ich schon gesagt durch diesen.
David Boder: Ja wahrscheinlich haben Sie das Meiste schon gesagt.
Wolf Nehrich: Ich spreche auch nicht gut Deutsch, weil ich, weil ich...
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: . . . ja Pole bin.
David Boder: Wann haben Sie das aufgeschrieben?
Wolf Nehrich: Das hab ich geschrieben schon nach der, nach der Befreiung.
David Boder: Aber Sie haben das selber aufgeschrieben, ja?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Was ist das? Wenn haben Sie das geschrieben?
Wolf Nehrich: Das? In, in, also voriges Jahr.
David Boder: Sie haben das schon ein Jahr...
Wolf Nehrich: Also.
David Boder: . . . zurück geschrieben?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Lesen Sie ein bisschen.
Wolf Nehrich: Weil, das ist, was ich schon einmal gesagt habe.
David Boder: Ja. Sehen Sie, wie sieht das aus hier, wie soll das werden?
Wolf Nehrich: Am 26. 9. 19. Also am 26. 9. 1945 hab ich das geschrieben.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Kurze Überlebnisse, kurze beschriebene Überlebnisse in elf Konzentrationslager über vier Jahre. Wolf Nehrich, geboren am 26. 12.
David Boder: Langsam.
Wolf Nehrich: 1928 in Debice [wahrscheinlich], Polen. Ich habe gewohnt in Königshütte bis Jahre 1939. Am 22. 10. 1939 wurde ich mit meiner Familie übersiedelt nach Będzin.
David Boder: Aha. Und dann, das ist das Selbe was wir hier haben.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mal, hat man nicht welche Witze in Konzentrationslagern mal erzählt? Ein Moment. [Hintergrundgeräusch]
Wolf Nehrich: Bitte?
David Boder: Hat man nicht welche Witze in Konzentrationslagern mal äh Geschichten, so was ähnliches, mal ein bissel Spaß gehabt?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein, man hat, vor allem hat man in seinem Kopf gehabt, man einfach, man hatte Hunger gehabt, und man ist gekommen von der Arbeit sehr müde. [Unverständlicher Satz]
David Boder: [spricht unverständlich über Nehrich] Ein junger Mann. Haben Sie einmal gedacht an ein Mädchen oder so?
Wolf Nehrich: Das hat mir überhaupt nie im Sinne gehabt. Niemals.
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Wolf Nehrich: Wie konnte man diese Sachen in dem Sinne haben, wenn man, wenn man Hunger gehabt hat, nicht wahr. Und man schwach war, man hat Arbeit gehabt, weil sich manchen geschaut, dass der Tag durchkommt, weil wir den Tag durchgelebt haben. Und man liegt auf die Pritschen, da hat man nur gesagt: Oder ein Tag näher zu der Befreiung, oder ein Tag näher zum Tod. Man wusste nicht was.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie gedacht, wie wird sich das dauern. Was, was...
Wolf Nehrich: Wer es hat Mut gehabt, der hat sich verschiedene Fantasien vorgestellt, der hat durchgelebt. Und wer hat gesagt, äh, weil so gestimmt, es hat äh geglaubt, ach, wer wird das durchhalten, man bekommt nichts zu essen, die schwere Arbeit, der ist vom bloß Denken ist er bald gestorben. Und ich hab immer gesagt, der äh, ein Jud bin ich geworden, ein Jud werd ich sein. Und äh wir Juden sind ein Leidentum, muss man immer weiterleiden, und ich will’s hoffen, dass ich, äh, dass man uns durchbringt. Doch hat man uns durchgebracht.
David Boder: Sagen Sie äh, hat man welche Gedichte im Lager gehabt?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, wir haben sogar ein Buchenwalder Lied haben wir auch gehabt. Vielleicht haben Sie es schon gehört?
David Boder: Wie war das, können Sie es äh langsam singen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Ich hab es hier aufgeschrieben sogar. Ich kann es auswendig auch, aber ich hab‘s.
David Boder: Ja, aber [unverständliches Wort]. Lesen Sie es schon ein bisschen mit der Melodie. Ja?
Wolf Nehrich: Bitte?
David Boder: Äh, singen Sie es vielleicht ein bisschen, dass man die Worte klar hört. Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Als das ist ein Lied äh.
David Boder: [unverständlicher Satz]
Wolf Nehrich: Das ist ein Lied, welches der Lagerkommandant aus Buchenwald hat verlangt, dass man soll ein Lied machen, und dafür hat gegeben 100 Zigaretten und äh, und äh zehn Mark. Aber die 100 Zigaretten hat man natürlich nicht gesehen.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Und die zehn Mark auch nicht, nur das Lied hat man gehabt.
David Boder: Aber dann war das Lied äh so, dass es den Deutschen gefallen sollte?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, das Lied war gemacht, nicht wahr, ein bisschen so äh weil wir dachten, das wird sie vielleicht nicht gefallen, aber die haben uns lassen das singen.
David Boder: Aha.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, wir müssen’s äh singen, manches Mal sogar wir haben Tote vom Lager von der Bausstelle reingebracht...
David Boder: Aha
Wolf Nehrich: in Lager. Musste man’s auch singen.
David Boder: Nun singen Sie.
Wolf Nehrich: Aber das Lied ist so, Buchenwalder Lied: „Wenn der Tag erwacht...“
David Boder: [unterbricht] Können Sie, singen Sie mit einer Melodie.
Wolf Nehrich: Ich hab heut schlechte Stimme.
David Boder: [unterbricht] Nein, nein, nein. überhaupt nicht. Singen Sie ganz leise, aber klare Worte.
Wolf Nehrich: [singt] „Wenn der Tag erwacht eh` die Sonne lacht. Die Kolonnen ziehen zu den Tagesmühen. Hinein in den grauenden Morgen. Und der Wald ist schwarz, und der Himmel rot, und der Wind singt leis’ und ich...“
David Boder: Lesen Sie, lesen Sie’s
Wolf Nehrich: [liest] „und ich trag, und wir tragen im Rucksack ein Stückchen Brot, und im Herzen, im Herzen die Sorgen. Ach Buchenwald, ich kann dich nicht vergessen, weil du mein Schicksal bist. Wer dich verlässt, der kann es erst ermessen, wie wunderbar die Freiheit ist. Doch Buchenwald, wir jammern nicht und klagen, und was auch unsere Zukunft sei, wir wollen trotzdem ja zum Leben sagen, weil einmal kommt der Tag, da sind wir frei.“
David Boder: Und das hat man erlaubt zu singen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Und weiter?
Wolf Nehrich: Ich will’s lieber äh nicht singen, weil ich habe...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Ja!
Wolf Nehrich: . . . keine gute Stimme.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: [liest] „Und die Nacht ist kurz und der Tag so lang, doch ein Lied erklingt, das die Heimat sang. Wir lassen den Mut uns nicht rauben. Halte Schritt Kamerad, und verlier nicht den Mut, denn wir tragen den Willen zum Leben im Blut, und im Herzen, im Herzen den Glauben. Ach Buchenwald, ich kann dich nicht vergessen, weil du mein Schicksal bist. Wer dich verlässt, der kann es erst ermessen, wie wunderbar die Freiheit ist. Doch Buchenwald, wir jammern nicht und klagen, und was auch uns-, unsere Zukunft sei, wir wollen trotzdem ja zum Leben sagen, weil einmal kommt der Tag dann sind wir frei.“
Wolf Nehrich: [liest] „Und das Blut ist heiß und das Mädel fern, und der Wind singt’s leis und ich habe sie so gern. Oh, wenn treu sie, wenn treu sie mir bliebe, und die Steine sind hart aber, hart aber fest und der Schritt, und wir tragen die Pickel und Spaten mit. Und im Herzen, im Herzen die Liebe. Ach Buchenwald, ich kann dich nicht vergessen, weil du mein Schicksal bist. Wer dich verlässt, der kann es erst ermessen, wie wunderbar die Freiheit ist. Doch Buchenwald, wir jammern nicht und klagen, und was auch uns unsere Zukunft sei, wir wollen trotzdem ja zum Leben sagen, weil einmal kommt der Tag, dann sind wir frei, frei, frei.“
David Boder: Ja. Und das hat man erlaubt zu singen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Wir mussten es sogar singen.
David Boder: Sie mussten es.
Wolf Nehrich: Wenn man manches Mal nicht im Kopf gehabt hat dazu, musste man es singen.
David Boder: Ja. Nun sagen Sie ruhig...
Wolf Nehrich: Das ist die Abzeichen von Buchenwald
David Boder: Ja. Soll das das Buchenwald-Zeichen? Dreieck, war das jüdisch oder politisch?
Wolf Nehrich: Politisch.
David Boder: Aha. Die Juden hat man die politischen [unverständliches Wort].
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Politisch und noch dazu oben einen gelben. Das war noch [unverständliches Wort].
David Boder: Ah nach oben waren gelbe Zeichen. Nun sagen Sie mir dies: Äh, wie. Äh. Ähm. Was halten Sie jetzt zu tun?
Wolf Nehrich: Jetzt, ähm, bin ich in der Fachschule von der ORT, ich lern Tischlerei. Die Fachschule ist sehr gut. Man kann sehr gut das Beruf lernen, vielleicht nicht so, äh vielleicht nirgends so gut wie in dieser Schule. Und nachher wenn ich die...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Tischlerei, dann.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja, Tischlerei. Wenn ich die Fach schon besser kenne, weiß nicht ob ich ihn ganz zu Ende bringen werde, hoffentlich ja, dann fahr ich nach Palästina.
David Boder: Ja. Nun sagen Sie mir dies: Ähm, und was ist dieser Platz wo Sie jetzt wohnen?
Wolf Nehrich: Das ist ein Jugendheim, nicht wahr, das ist eine religiöse Heim. Die Religiösen, die religiös woll-, sein wollen. Nun sind sie hier in diesem Heim, nicht wahr, genauso wie in all alle anderen Heimen.
David Boder: Und wieso haben beschlossen relig-, religiös zu sein? [Unverständlicher Satzanfang] waren Sie zwölf Jahre ungefähr. Waren Ihre Eltern religiös?
Wolf Nehrich: Meine Eltern waren religiös. Und ich hab anerkannt, dass man muss religiös sein.
David Boder: Wann haben Sie das anerkannt?
Wolf Nehrich: Ich hab die ganze, durch die ganze Zeit gesehen, nicht wahr, ich hab immer, trotzdem ich war in die große Gefahr, die ganze Zeit hab ich immer an Gott geglaubt, und ich hab’s durchgebracht, dass ich weiter an Gott glaub.
David Boder: Hat man erlaubt den Juden zu beten im Lager?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein, das nicht. Man hat, man hat manches Mal gebetet, ver-, ganz versteckt.
David Boder: Ja.
Wolf Nehrich: Aber es war verboten. Streng verboten. Wenn man jemanden gefun-, gefangen hatte, hat er nachher Stockschläge bekommen.
David Boder: Aha. So [unverständliches Wort] hat man nicht gehabt?
Wolf Nehrich: Nein, das war nicht.
David Boder: Hat man ein Gebetbuch gehabt?
Wolf Nehrich: Es konnte vielleicht je jemand haben ge-, eingenäht, und konnte dann vielleicht irgendwo versteckt im ganzen Lager.
David Boder: Aha. So was hat, wie hat man gebetet?
Wolf Nehrich: Auswendig, wie einer konnte.
David Boder: Aha. Und, äh, haben viele gewusst die jüdischen Gebete auswendig? Haben Sie welche gewusst?
Wolf Nehrich: [spricht über Boder] Wer hat gewusst, der hat gewusst. Hat nicht jeder, hat man nicht immer hat man gebetet. Manches mal, man hat gesagt die [unverständliches Wort] auswendig, oder mal die [unverständliches Wort; beides wohl Namen bestimmter jüdischer Gebete] und damit schon etwas.
David Boder: Aha. Und warum haben Sie gesagt, dass äh Sachen geformen die äh, na ja. Nun, äh, so jetzt planen Sie nach Palästina zu gehen?
Wolf Nehrich: Ja.
David Boder: Und ihr Bruder will nach Palästina.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Zusammen mit dem Bruder.
David Boder: Wie denken Sie, wie werden Sie rüberkommen?
Wolf Nehrich: Wieso? Was, wie, wie eine Möglichkeit sein wird, auf so eine Art wird man rübergehen.
David Boder: Nun, das war sehr gut Herr äh Nehrich. Es freut mich wirklich, dass ich herübergekommen bin. Und ich denke, alles wird gut sein. Und wenn ich den Rabbiner Schächter sehe, werde ich ihm einen Gruß übergeben.
Wolf Nehrich: Ja. Sehr angenehm.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Wolf Nehrich eh, in Geneva, on, eh, August the 26th 1946. We curtail, that we finish that at, eh, the spool of 25 minutes. He has spoken one full spool and 25 minutes on the other. And that is about all. Eh, Illinois Institute of Technology recording.